[Musique]
le premier marché des producteurs a été
organisé ce jeudi 4 août à Saint-Pierre
l'occasion pour nassimaar président du
département et Serge warirot conseiller
départemental en charge de l'agriculture
de rappeler les objectifs de ces
rendez-vous en présence du sénateur
maire Michel Fontaine et de Jean-Bernard
contier président de la Chambre
d'Agriculture
voilà pays que nous défend le
vice-président avec nous parce que ça
c'est la réunion que nous aim et
l'agriculture que nous aim monsieur éc
pour
le une vingtaine de producteurs avaient
fait le déplacement sur le front de mer
Saint-Pierrois et les nombreux visiteurs
ont pu découvrir des fruits et légumes
bio des plantes médicinales ou encore
des produits locaux transformé j'ai déjà
participé au marché pays de jardin et là
aujourd'hui B c'est la première qui se
font sur Saint-Pierre voilà je participe
pour la première fois moi je trouve
c'est bien c'est une très bonne journée
déjà qu'on a eu B il fait beau c'est
super et puis ben c'est aussi encore une
opportunité pour nous ce que nous offre
le Conseil Général moi je suis nous
sommes une ferme auberge nous faisons du
canard surtout donc j'ai des magr du
foas des des riettes des confit quelques
PL cuisinés des canards et des achars et
des confitures ça permet à des petits
producteurs comme nous comme nos
collègues qui de vendre leurs produits
sans passer par le marché où il faut
payer la place tout
ça bah pour moi je trouve que c'est
c'est excellent c'est bon je fais le
march Saint-Joseph mais là c'est un
autre marché pour moi je vois beaucoup
plus de monde et puis j'ai et c'est de
bouche à l'oreille j'ai connu que j'
avait un marché comme ça j'aiux pour la
première fois pour essayer je vois que
c'est magnifique c'est bien je suis venu
présenter tout ce qui me dit fruitier en
particulier ben le citron caviar comme
vous pouvez voir mais après tout ce
qu'on va dire citron galet citron 4
saison le kombava surtout fruitier et
agrume ça fait connaître surtout les
agriculteurs pour certains c'est moi
personnellement c'est la première fois
que je le fais et je trouve que c'est
une bonne chose quand même pour nous
faire connaître déjà dans un premier
temps et pouvoir développer un peu les
marchés un marché qui a également permis
de réaffirmer que le département
autorité de gestion des fonds féadair
soutien et grroit au développement de
l'île à travers son agriculture nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans un dispositif
qui est en vigueur qui a été actionné et
avec le fader l'objectif c'est de
pouvoir véritablement donner tous les
moyens financier pour nos agriculteurs
tant au niveau de l'accompagnement dans
le transfert de connaissance
l'encadrement technique que sur les
investissement puisque les dispositifs
qui sont actionnés aujourd'hui
concernent les investissements en
matière de bâtiment d'élevage de
structure de serre sur de la
mécanisation sur l'amélioration du
foncier agricole nous avons comme cela
tout le panel de de dispositifs qui est
aujourd'hui actionné et qui sont mis à
disposition des agriculteurs et nous les
invitons aujourd'hui à inviter à à
présenter leur dossier à s'adresser aux
différents services instructeurs pour
véritablement libérer les fonds qui sont
mis à leur disposition le prochain
marché pays se déroulera à l'espace
redley à Saint-Denis le 13 août 2016
[Musique]